can you explain the importance of the
collaboration process between writers
directors and producers okay first I
want to add another category which is
actors okay writers directors producers
and actors first of all the the whole
process of making a film is a
collaboration process that if a writer
didn't want to collaborate they would
write a novel but director didn't want
to collaborate he might do something
else yeah in fact you might become a
painter or something like that the
storytelling through film is by design
collaboration the problem is there's so
little collaboration that actually goes
on or such inefficient or ineffective
collaboration going on so there is
collaboration but what we Michael and I
are doing is with this process beyond
collaboration that's what we're calling
it as we're addressing that
collaboration process and trying to
explore how people can be more effective
can be more efficient how writers can
learn how to not only work with
directors but work with actors work with
producers and in fact those four
categories how they can learn a language
a common language that they can all
speak to each other because rarely do
they ever speak to each other except
usually just directors and actors and
that's it all right
anything to add no I agree completely
with what he said I just think it's a
the best movies come when those elements
work together for one thing I think it's
essential that those people find some
common vision for the movie I think the
biggest mistakes come when the writer
has a vision the script is taken over by
somebody else and they they neither
replace it with their own or understand
the writers vision and now it just
becomes a patchwork of different ideas
about what that story is rather than a
unified idea of this is what we're
trying to say with this film and
collaboration is really going to enable
them to do that why does the
collaboration break down fear
I think a lot fear and mistrust I think
fear I think too many artists all four
of those categories feared that they
don't know enough about the story don't
know about enough about what they're
doing and it'll show so it's best not to
talk to furnaces a director who doesn't
want to work with the writer and you say
why not the writer created this script
that you are going to make into a film
why wouldn't you want to talk with him
why wouldn't you want to collaborate
with him and a lot of directors that I
work with and I've worked with him here
and overseas Europe and it's almost a
consistent thing that the director feels
he has to be the authority he has to be
the leader and if he starts
collaborating with other people it may
be exposed that he doesn't know what
he's doing to enough depth understanding
of it so best just to stay away from
that
I think directors too and even producers
a lot of times feel if we let the writer
to continue to be involved once they've
turned on this turned over the script
then if we start to try new things or
try new ideas they're gonna dig their
heels in and not be cooperative and so
the writer gets pushed out of the
picture and this has always been the way
in Hollywood since the beginning really
and so the writer is kind of left behind
and everybody else goes to it whereas
good writers writers that I've worked
with many times relish the idea of
working with people and changing their
own scripts for the better and working
together to realize their vision even
more strongly but there's just so seldom
that opportunity you've got to have a
director that is willing and not afraid
of bringing the group together working
with writers and everybody's standing up
for their vision of the story before you
decide this is the way it's going to be
yeah and I think I think there's also a
fear and when I say fear I know I mean
just the director or just the
resurrected writer actor producer the
this is really interesting a fear that's
somebody else okay I'm the director my
fear that somebody else the writer the
actor or the producer will have a
better idea a really good idea and now
what do I do with that if I'm not
confident with my own craft and what I'm
doing if I'm not secure and my vision of
where I want to take this movie I can be
threatened by a good idea and I mean a
really good idea and many times the
writer will have that good idea the
writer can say well I always saw this
scene being done this way there's a
vision so now the the writer has a
vision of how the scene might be played
or where it might be played or the
location or the tone and a secured
director can listen to that and go great
idea I'm gonna use part of it or some of
it or none of it and still feel
confident it feel like his authority has
not been threatened a weak director will
hear that great idea and feel threatened
because he doesn't know what to do with
it so basically the writers gone that
you know that's why let's not let the
writer and same thing Michael say
because but the other thing is my
feeling because of the collaboration
process between these four elements
producer director writer and actors
there is the potential which is what I'm
always going for that if we all get
together and we all collaborate and we
all share our ideas and our visions for
this movie that we're all working to
make this one thing happen the chances
are that the final product that we will
create if we're all open to each other
trust each other and are confident and
secure the final product will rise above
what any one of us could have done alone
and we will at the end not know quite
how it happened and that's the magic of
what can happen but this but that means
giving up control everybody director
writer producers actors everybody has to
give up control the control is taken
over by the creative process not by
another person but by a creative process
and that creative process can then
elevate the film
you